je suis vraiment impatient
c'est aujourd'hui que je dois recevoir
la nouvelle patinette que doit m'envoyer
ma tante adélaïde
je vais vous lire sa lettre
mon cher casimir je t'envoie pour tu as
fait une patinette une oeuvre j'espère
qu'elle te plaira et surtout que tu
seras très prudent car dans l'île il y à
beaucoup d'enfants qui jouent ouais t'as
tante adélaïde qui t'aime bien etc
elle est vraiment gentille ma tante non
j'entends du bruit ça va être émile
campagne qui me laporte
c vous factor vous avez quelque chose
pour noir si j'ai quelque chose pour toi
tout essoufflé et asie mais à ce jeu ce
colis très encombrant ça y est je suis
sûr que ces matinées
3d live qui me l'envoie je vous aide a
déclaré
qu'elle est
orientée imaginait un regard des mérous
tourne bien
laisser là moi je dois attendre plus
longtemps je vais l'essayer tout de
suite c'est attention elles soient
prudents et oui mais oui un mois la
vitesse a relevé aux espaces legault
dans le visage
[Musique]
es4 casimir attention limitation owen
les amis mes amis mes amis je suis venu
vos points de vie casimir risque d'avoir
un accident ld partout sur sa nouvelle
patinette et il parcourt toute l'île
sans ralentir et bien vous voilez
souffre les acteurs télé voilà un verre
de limonade bien fraîche en aussi jolie
s'était pas drôle
bon j'ai pris un raccourci un à travers
les bois les taillis pour éviter de me
trouver sur le chemin de ce fou de
casimir
n'ayez comme facteur casimir à faire un
petit tour il va très vite s'habituer à
son nouvel engin oui mais sur les
patinettes ya pas de fin et ni
d'avertisseurs casimir freinera avec ses
pieds et comme il a des des grands
billets ah oui oui pour avertir ifa
et comme il a une grosse voix
[Musique]
et
voilà alors tu es content thézillieu en
formidable c'est engins les performances
mais n'est pas par julie lui est arrivé
magnifique oui oui mais tu vas quand
même un peu vite hein mais non pas du
tout bon allez attention je repars
non je n'ai rien ça va c'est à cause du
temps rayon de soleil dans l'orient
je vais voir si la patinette n'a pas
trop souffert il faudra voir choc au
parc chocat était émirats perchoc c'est
une pièce métallique con mais comme ça
qui se vissent ici et qui sert à
protéger larobina qu'henri mais pour
l'heure la famille dans l'orgue
toutefois par un sol casimir viens je
vais te chercher celui de julie ah bon
alors bien le
voilà
c'est parfait bon voila et coûteuse
jamais chez moi installer un rapport
choc s'avère plus prudents voire
ça y'est françois j'ai installé là le
pare chocs sur ma platine est très bien
mais je voudrais te demander conseil je
t'écoute casimir
j'ai donc à par chance pour les champs
paris en parasol pour le soleil arrive
comment faut-il en cas de pluie
casimir c'est très simple il va lui
demander aux enfants accor après dix
mois les enfants venaient au nez
installez-vous dans l'herbe
casimir a besoin d'eux
je vais vous montrer un certain nombre
de dessins qui représentent des objets
qui commencent tous par parra qui siège
à se protéger de quelque chose vous
allez vivre un casino ce que c'est
d'accord
j'en ai un jour ma patrie n'est oui
c'est vrai à quoi ça sert de parasols
oui c'est fabriqué en quoi
très bien
ça qu'est ce que c'est un emmental non
exactement se protéger du vent celui ci
en réalité c'est un paravent
d'appartements il sert plutôt à se
protéger quand on se change par exemple
à se protéger des regards tiens
qu'est-ce que c'est
oui quand on se jette d'un avion
voilà c'est pour ralentir la chute est
parce qu en arrivant au sol
voilà ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est c'est
ça la c'est un tara
paratonnerre et c'est une pièce
métallique qui situé sur la partie la
plus haute d'une maison qui sert à quoi
[Musique]
c'est ça la foudre est attiré par le
paratonnerre elle suit la tige
métallique elle va s'enfoncer là dans
l'eau quelques fois c'est dans la terre
ceux ci qu'est ce que c'est
il soutient par action
exactement et c'est fabriqué en coin
en toile imperméable surtout pour la
casim et objets c'était très intéressant
et cela m'a donné une excellente idée je
vais faire une très grande surprise à
julie
reposez-vous cinq minutes facteurs julie
leur avenir dans cinq minutes bon à vrai
dire je n'ai pas de courrier pour elle
mais par ces temps-ci chaud ah oui
peut-être qu'un bon petit verre de
limonade bien frais mais comment avez
vous pu deviner françois parce que
pourtant je n'ai rien dit je suis c'est
parce que vous êtes cinq ans peut-être
d'acteurs peut-être voilà julie
justement
je suis très content que vous voir vous
savez du courrier pondre pas précisément
non mais comme je disais à françois par
ces temps-ci chou
vous aimeriez un petit verre dans les
manuels voilà
casimir mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
salut julie tu viens voir ma nouvelle
invention m au kiosque mais regarde j'ai
pensé que chaque chose séparément
n'était pas assez efficace a alors j'ai
inventé le pas à tous ainsi tokyo ce
nous ne risquera rien et le plus
important sera protégé il n'arrivera
rien à tes bonbons quoi qu'il arrive à
[Musique]